i'm just getting flashbacks or something
that happened when i was like a [ __ ]
teenager
it was it wasn't actually to do with me
but it's this is probably like one of
the most british stories i've ever seen
happen in the airport so uh we i was
visiting spain with some mates and we
were in the south of spain normal kind
of british holiday and so we are on our
way to fly back
and we see
that there's another british guy in
front of us
that uh has been basically stopped at
the security gate because in spain or
yeah in spain
so because it was found that he had a
bottle of uh a liter bottle of vodka
that obviously you can't take liquids on
the plane he had a liter bottle of vodka
that he tried to pass through security
and so security told him to get rid of
the bottle right
and they give him the bit
he goes no i'm going to choose the
second option
is he in line he starts [ __ ] chucking
this little bomb
and he's like no i refuse to throw this
away [ __ ] you don't just kick him off
the flight they should kick him off the
floor i don't know because the only
reason i know this because i see this i
see him chugging this ball and everyone
that he goes past he offers a swing to
him
depending on what mood i was in i
would potentially and i'm like this is
the most british thing i've ever seen
someone who's just refusing to throw
away this little bottle of vodka and
just decides to chug it before security
i definitely think he could have
lingered for a while and like you're
forgetting the other option
make them say it
[Music]
the only weirdest thing that i've ever
had at an airport or on a plane was that
um i was on a plane from amsterdam to
london
and as the plane landed
uh there was like an announcement where
they were like hey so
uh somebody was smoking in the toilet so
we're gonna the police are gonna come on
and take the person off and then yeah
that's gonna be it so we're literally
waiting two dudes come on go to the back
pick this guy up take him off
and and it was like oh
i didn't even know what that was weird
he just
yeah he just police came on took him off
i don't know what happens when you do it
i assume they probably
away from it the thing that blew my mind
is that that flight is an hour and 20
minutes you couldn't hold it it's like
this what i'm saying like yeah an hour
and 20 minutes you can't hold it or like
wait like i i'd have a little bit more
sympathy if it was 16 hours and i'm like
you're a complete crippling at smoking
like you're going to amsterdam what else
are you going to do yeah
you're gonna smoke you can do it there
just i just i i didn't understand it and
like i during the flight after i heard
that i was like i did smell smoke at one
point but i just thought i was
crazy i thought i was just having a
stroke
i thought i thought i was like
i'm going crazy yeah because yeah
because when you when you always hear
the safety instructions of like don't
smoke in the toilets because you know
it's a federal offense it's like it's
like you don't have to tell me that no
one's stupid enough to do that there's
an ashtray in the toilet for a reason
people smoke probably better than
throwing in the trap yeah you can't
because they want if people are going to
smoke they want them to put it out in
the ashtray yeah as opposed to throwing
it in the trash and lighting it on fire
right because it's literally just
tissues right yeah so that's the reason
why they have ashtrays on every plane
and i
you know is that true why do you think
there's an ashtray on every toilet i
don't know i it's just to keep people
from throwing it in the trash cause if
they would have try and put it out in
the trash the last thing you want is a
bigger fire yeah
so if you're going to smoke on the plane
at least for god's sake put it out yeah
the right way yeah can we fact check
this yeah i'm telling you this is why i
definitely believe it
yeah
you know they're gonna do something bad
so you give them the best way to do it
better yeah because i like cause like if
people are gonna break the rules at
least let them break the rules in a safe
way and then punish them because i've
never really thought about it but i've
always thought i've always seen the
ashtray and i've always seen people say
please don't smoke on the tread on the
plane so i was like was there an era i
wasn't alive where they were just
allowed to smoke on the planes that's
like how i've rationalized it in my mind
yeah they were you were allowed yeah
what's the verdict yeah that's correct
yeah
by the federal aviation administration
yeah my dad used to work for airbus
really project managed putting the wings
together and he told me about it i was
like that sounds wrong so you so you can
smoke no no no no no no you can't right
you're not allowed to but like it's like
but if you do
at least there's a national trust it's
like a clean needle program it's like
you know they're going to do drugs right
so at least do it with a clean safe like
don't
you know there's a lot of things that
you design where you know people are
going to break the rules there's no way
you can stop it so at least do it so it
doesn't [ __ ] everyone else so why is
that on like a pack of condoms for
anyone who wants to go into my hog mile
because who if someone gets chlamydia on
the plane there's an effect
yeah
you're not gonna hear an announcement
like oh yeah
you're not going to hear it nasa would
be like yeah so someone uh in the back
uh has crabs now for some reason uh two
security guards could come and take him
away harry just got syphilis and he's
gonna die and that doesn't leave
like
i think the worst thing i ever saw on a
flight and it's not even that bad was
right as a plane was landing this woman
who didn't speak english gets up out of
her seat to go use the bathroom and they
started freaking out like i think they
were like inches away from aborting the
landing right but they realized that
pretty much no matter what they did was
gonna be like the most dangerous thing
for that situation yeah so they were
screaming they're like do not like leave
like stay in the bathroom stay seated
like complete like litter of the plane's
like coming in for its landing
gets up and goes to the bathroom
what yeah
i don't know i don't think she i don't
know what happened i think i just got
the plan what the [ __ ] yeah i don't
think you get arrested or fined for that
but i think like you can you can get
fined
and get fired i'm pretty sure like if
you're doing [ __ ] like that and landing
it's putting everybody else in danger
yeah yeah because if they like have to
abort or they make a are you costing
tens of thousands of dollars yeah yeah
exactly or if they get someone injured
from falling over and smacking their
head on something yeah yeah it's a
liability yeah
so we're allowed to land it's like bet
hawaii i don't think so
i don't think i've ever seen anything
that crazy on a flight before that's
pretty crazy
i'm kind of crazy i sometimes leave my
cell phone signal
after they leave before landing i'd put
my seat back
i hate
[Laughter]
that lands you what like twenty five
thousand dollar fine and like actual
jail time if you i think it's jail time
with that that's jail time it depends on
the country okay
hey
is that a tax write-off you get a fine
with the intent of
getting getting a fine for a video idea
is that a tax writer that
i i
i don't think so no idea i have no idea
no one's put that to the test yet
i don't like this why not
i shouldn't have given you that idea
actually
i don't know if you're gonna but if you
get a dui and you're filming it is that
is that a write-off
laws don't exist if you're filming it
right yeah i don't know this that's why
it's like i'd be like please mr
accountability
always been interested not personally
but it's like scientifically the whole
how much alcohol can you drink and then
drive yeah thing yeah like because it's
based on the drive or drive legally i
drive legally
but obviously if you're a really big guy
it's like you can drink a lot more than
that i've always wondered because of how
it works you could easily drink if you
were a giant guy very big yeah drink
four beers drive and then you would
still come up as legal to drive yeah
we don't condone any of this behavior no
no no no no
i know what we're saying it's a
hypothetical nor should we nor are we
saying anyone should test it out yeah
it's like what you mentioned like it has
been arbitrarily set at yeah two yeah
yeah roughly they think that that is
yeah that's the average right the
percentage is what like 0.08 percent i
don't know
well in japan it's zero
zero percent yeah that's like nothing it
feels like kind of actually almost like
false positives have come out of that
maybe i don't know i never thought about
it i i've never driven and had a drink
at any point so yes because like you
could have a drink and then like hours
later like three hours later yeah you
actually still have something yeah yeah
yeah exactly like i think like there was
a massive problem where in the uk where
people would go on like an all-night
bender yeah and then drive to work the
next day and they were still drunk and
still over the limit in the morning
because they drunken so much the night
before right and late into the night
yeah yeah as well yeah so you know it's
like your brain says oh i sleep
therefore i'm sober it's a really good
way of avoiding that it's just don't
drink absurd amount of alcohol for work
i feel like that's generally the life i
think that's good advice regardless of
if you're driving or not it's just a
that's a simple lifestyle maybe that's a
bit too smart
that's why i like the city though
because it's like you don't have to
think about it here you just get on the
freaking train yeah okay here's the
thing though in japan is it everyone
goes out and gets drunk on weekdays and
then goes to work yeah so
yeah
well yeah i think you're just
participating in the culture yeah yeah
exactly being an honorary japanese